翻訳: Keiko Ishigami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
はい皆さん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
先ほど話された土井先生は
宇宙に行ったことがある人ですけれども
私は望遠鏡を使ったり
あるいは物理学の理論を使ったりして
宇宙のことを見ている
宇宙のことを調べている天文学者です
同時に 先程土井先生も
紹介されましたけれども
京大の中で「宇宙ユニット」といって
文系まで含めて
幅広い学問を総合して
宇宙のことを色々考えてみようという
そういうユニットに
私も長いこと参加していまして
今日私が話をするのは
私の専門の天文学というよりは
私がここ何年か人文系の先生方と一緒に
開拓してきた新しい宇宙の学問のことを
この写真 随分古い写真に
見えますけれども
これは太平洋戦争前ですね
1940年前後に
京都大学の花山天文台で行われた
一般公開の写真です
着物姿 もんぺ姿の人々が
望遠鏡を見ているのが見えますね
遥か昔からですね
人間は宇宙に興味を持ってきたわけです
そして宇宙に憧れを持って 好奇心を持って
宇宙のことを知りたいと思ってきた
私も
宇宙に興味を持って
天文学者になったわけですけども
何で 人は宇宙に惹かれるのか
という話を最初にしたいと思います
この前に 皆さんにお見せしているのは
紫外線で見た太陽ですね
これは本当の太陽の写真です
紫外線ですけれども
ここにちっちゃーく 地球がありますね
大体これ位の大きさになります
位置はもっと本当は遠いですけど
太陽は地球の100倍位あります
大きな星です
で実はですね
世の中にはですね この宇宙には
もっと大きな星があります
これは「赤色巨星」という
真っ赤ですごく大きな星です
これは 本当に赤色巨星の写真を
見ているわけではなくって
これ位大きいのっていうのを
説明するためにですね
ここに太陽を置いて
地球の100倍大きい太陽が
この位の大きさだとすると
こんなに大きな星が
世の中にはいっぱいあるんですね
私は 子供の頃に
この赤色巨星のことを絵本で読んで
世の中にこんなでかいものがあるのかと
それはワクワク感というよりは
半分以上は恐怖だったんですね
恐ろしいと思いました
怖いけども[ワクワクする]
その怖さとワクワク感の
入り混じったような世界にすごく惹かれて
宇宙のことを好きになりました
で 私は京大以外にですね
京都精華大学という芸大でも
授業をしているんですけども
そこで芸術を学ぶ学生さんにですね
「宇宙のことがめっちゃ好きなんです」
ていう人がいました
「あなたが 宇宙のことに
触れる時に感じる感動は
他のどういう時に感じる感動と似てますか？」
とその人に聞いたらですね
彼女はしばらく考えて
「めっちゃ変わったフェチの人を見た時」
と答えました
皆さん 意味分かりますか？
僕はすごくよく分りました
これは僕にとっての赤色巨星と一緒なんです
つまり 自分の理解を超えた存在
自分の日常感覚を超えた存在
自分の知っている世界ではない世界
でもそれが本当にそこにあるんだって
いうことに対する感動なんですね
自分の知っている世界だけが世界ではなくて
自分では全く知らない世界が
でもそこにはあるっていう
この世界に対する憧れというか
恐怖も混じるかもしれませんが
そういうものが宇宙の魅力だと
僕は思っています
ダンゴムシの話はこれだけなんですけども
まぁ 私はこれは ー
そういう宇宙でですね
人文社会系の学門をする意味はどこにあるのか
という話をする時によく紹介する話です
私の研究ではなくて
信州大学の森山徹さんという
動物行動学者の方がですね
『ダンゴムシに心はあるのか』
という本を書いておられます
で 森山さんはどういう研究を
したかというとですね
ダンゴムシって 不思議な性質があって
右左右左と交互に曲がるんですね
障害物にぶつかる毎に
それはその方が
逃げるのに有利なんですけども
それはある種ダンゴムシの小さな小さな
神経細胞の中に刻み込まれた —
本能のようなものだと
皆んな思っているわけです
で 森山さんは何をしたかというとですね
そのダンゴムシをある迷路の中に入れた
その迷路は 自動的にくるくる
回せるようになっていて
ずーっと ダンゴムシが右左右左と曲がると
同じ所をずっと行ったり来たり
するようになる仕掛けがあるんです
そして彼は何を発見したかというと
ダンゴムシはですね 何十回か
行ったり来たりを繰り返すと
キレます
ムキ―となって壁を登り出したり
ぐるぐる回り出したり
右右右と回ったり
今までしなかった —
彼らの本能にはないと思われていた
振る舞いをします
で 森山さんはそれを
ダンゴムシの隠された心だと
つまり単調作業に耐えられなくなる
彼らには心があるんだと
そういうふうに言われるわけですね
これを本当に心と呼ぶかどうかは
解釈が色々とあるでしょうから
置いときましょう
でも大事なことは
このダンゴムシの知られざる性質は
自然の中でダンゴムシを観察しても
多分 わからなかった
そうじゃなくて
ダンゴムシ的にあり得ない
新しい環境に置いたからこそ
そのダンゴムシの知られざる性質が
見えてきたわけです
つまりある対象を
その対象にとって全く新しい世界
非常に極端に異なる世界 新しい環境
そういう所に置いてやると
その置かれた対象の今まで知られていなかった
性質が明らかになることがある
というわけで
宇宙は 人間にとっての新しい環境です
つまりダンゴムシの
新しい 知られなかった心が
迷路の中で見い出されたように
人間が宇宙に行くことで
人間もしくは人間の集団が作る社会
それらの今まで知られていなかった性質が
明らかになるかもしれない
そして僕自身が天体のことを知りたいと思って
宇宙のことを知りたいと思って
天文学者になったように
人間のことを知りたい
人間が作る社会について知りたいと思って
その好奇心によって
駆動された学問というのが
人文社会系の学問ですよね
つまり 人間のことを知りたい
社会のことを知りたいと思っている —
人文社会系の学問にとってこそ
人間が宇宙に行き始めた今
宇宙はそれらの学問の
フィールドになりつつあるわけです
なので私はここ何年か
色んな人文系の研究者と一緒に
人文社会社会系の研究者と一緒に
宇宙と「何とか学」みたいな
研究をいっぱい始めようとしてきました
そのうちの１つが
「倫理学と宇宙」という分野です
倫理学 皆さんどんな学問か
想像つきますかね？
倫理 ー
つまり人間はどう振舞うべきか
どういうものに価値を見出すのか
そういうことに興味を持って
探求している学問です
哲学の一分野です
もちろん 宇宙開発には
様々な倫理問題が付きまといます
例えば 宇宙飛行士の安全は
どこまで確保されるべきであるかとか
それから 人工衛星のデータがですね
どんどん解像度が良くなってくると
今度はプライバシーの問題があります
そのプライバシーの問題と
衛星データが向上することによる利便性は
どちらを優先されるべきか
まぁ 色んな倫理問題があります
そういう宇宙開発に伴う
様々な倫理問題を解決するためにも
倫理学は必要なんですけれども
もっと大事なのはそれではない
そうではなくて
人間の倫理とはどういうものか
人間はどういうものに価値を見出しているのか
どのように振舞うべきなのか
という倫理学の根源的な問題について
宇宙という新しい環境が
新たな視点を投げかけてくれるわけです
例えば 我々は火星の環境
今もしかしたら微生物が
住んでいるかもしれませけど
まあ 砂漠みたいな所ですよね
それを我々の住みやすいように変えることは
それって火星の環境破壊なんじゃないか？
逆に 我々人間がそういう
非常に異なる環境に行くときに
環境を変えられないなら
我々が変わるしかないですよね
生きていくためには
例えば 遺伝子工学や
細胞技術みたいなものを使って
人間を改変すること
それは今の地球ではもちろん
倫理的に許されないとしています
でもそれが
火星とか他の天体という新しい環境で
生きていくために必要なことだとしたら
その倫理の前提は変わるかもしれない
そんなふうに
宇宙という全く異なる状況がですね
我々の価値判断 「何をすべきか？」
ということを考える —
前提となっているようなことを
ひっくり返してくれる
そのことによって我々は
倫理というものに対して
より深く考えることができるわけです
まぁそんなことを
倫理学者と一緒にやったりしています
歴史研究者と一緒に研究もしています
私自身天文学者として
太陽のですね
太陽活動や太陽の爆発とかを
研究しているのですけども
太陽で爆発が起こると
何が月で起きるか？
一番昔から起きることが知られているのは
オーロラです
「太陽でどれ位大きな
爆発が起きるのか」というのは
「どれ位大きな地震が起こるか」
と一緒ですね
色々面白いことなんですけども
何せ 近代観測は
100年位しか歴史がありません
でも昔から人々は
天変地異を記録してきました
例えばここに —
後ろに出している絵はですね
江戸時代くらいにですね
日本 しかも京都くらいでも
オーロラが見えたんです
京都で真赤なオーロラが
見えたことがあります 1770年です
その時の
日本中で見えたオーロラの絵を
表しています
この右上のは
本当のオーロラの写真ですけども
でですね 当時はもちろん
人々はオーロラなんて知らなかったので
火事かと思って屋根に水をかけたり
色々なことをしています
で 日本の記録だけではなくて
例えばバビロニアのですね
粘土板に刻み込まれた楔型文字の中にも
オーロラのみたいな記録が残っています
そういう天文学者には読めないけれども
歴史学研究者達が読んでいる文献を読むことで
我々は過去の太陽活動を知ることができる
だから歴史文献がサイエンスに役立つ
それだけではなくて
こういう天変地異を見た時に
人々がどのように反応していったか
ということをつぶさに見てやるとですね
例えば日本とか中国といった
東アジアでですね
自然科学 近代科学みたいなものが
どんなふうに人々の考え方の中に
根付いてきたかということの
変遷を見ることができます
昔は 天変は空からのお告げだったわけですよ
地上の政治が悪いから神様が怒った
みたいな そういうことです
でも だんだん だんだん人々の記録は
客観的になってきてですね
「これ確か100年に前に起きたと
うちのじっちゃんが言っていたあれかな？」
みたいな そんな記述が出てくるんです
だんだん だんだん 人々が
迷信の世界から科学の世界に
あるいは宗教的な考え方から
合理的な考え方に
少しずつ遷移してくる —
これを追っかけることになる
それは どちらかというと
歴史研究者の興味です
我々は天文学者と歴史研究者が
一緒に研究することによって
天文学のサイエンスにも役立つし
そういう人間の考え方の歴史も
同時に研究しています
「宇宙人類学」というのをやっています
宇宙人の研究ではありません
人類が宇宙に行く
そのことが人類に何をもたらすか
という研究です
これ 有名な写真ですね
アポロ17号が撮った地球の写真です
この写真を見て皆さん 何を思いますか？
きれいだなと思いますか？
この写真はアポロ計画というですね
まぁ言うなれば 米ソの冷戦 軍事競争の
産物としてあった宇宙のミッションが
しかしこの宇宙から見た
この暗闇に浮かぶ青い星の写真を
皆さんに見せることによって
あっ人類皆兄弟なんだなと
この上で殺し合うのはあまりに馬鹿馬鹿しい
ということを教えてくれた写真ですよね
でも同時にこの写真は
別のことも訴えかけています
ここから出たら生きられないんじゃないか
っていう閉塞感です
そう思いませんか
ここから出たら[生き]られない
こんな小さな地球
我々 今 グローバル化という名の下に
地球はどんどん狭くなっています
どんどん人々の行き来も容易になってくる
そして
コミュニケーションも容易になってくる
それは 我々に何をもたらすか？
それは 良い面ももたらしますが
別の側面は 文化の画一化・均一化です
文化人類学者のレヴィ・ストロースが
こんな言葉を残しています
「想像に満ちた偉大な時代とは
遠く離れたパートナーと
刺激を与え合える程度に情報交換ができ
しかもその頻度と速度は
集団・個人間に不可欠の壁を小さくしすぎて
交換が容易になり画一化が進み
多様性が見失われない程度に
留まっていた時代」
すなわち文化人類学者の
レヴィ・ストロースが言っていることは
本当に人間がクリエイティブであるためには
人間の集団の間には
ある種の隔絶がないといけない
あまりにもコミュニケーションが
容易になってしまう
行き来が容易になってしまって
まさにTEDのコンセプトです
「Idears worth spreading」は
地球全体にスプレッドした結果
みんなそのアイディアを持っちゃったら
なんてつまらない世界だろうと
でも今や地球上は
すごく狭くなっています
交通手段の発達
そしてインターネットの発達によって
非常にコミュニケーションが
容易になっている
もう人間はクリエイティブに
なれないんじゃないか？
じゃあどうする？
遠いところに行ったらいいんじゃない？と
（笑）
ちょっと無理やりですかね
でも実際に 行こうと
している人がいるわけです
火星に移住とかね
他の天体に行こうとしている人たちが
その火星に行こうとしている人たちがね
人類の多様性を求めて行っているのか
どうかは知りません
ですが 私自身は
人類が地球を出て
他の天体 宇宙に行くことは
地球のためになるとは
何となくあんまり思えません
だけどもこの人類全体が
狭いところで どんどん どんどん
文化や考え方が画一化してしまって
創造性を無くしてしまっているときにですね
全く離れた環境において
我々地球の文明からある程度孤立した —
ちょっとは往き来があるけど —
ある程度孤立した文明が
そこにできるということは
おそらく人類の新たな多様性の種に
なるんじゃないかと思っています
さあ で 多様性は
みんな好きな言葉ですけれども
じゃあ 本当に嬉しいのか その多様性は
もちろん色んなものがあるのは
まあ一般的には良いことですよね
だけども例えばさっき
倫理のところで言ったように
宇宙っていう極端な環境で
人々が住むとしたら
その人たちは遺伝子工学を使って
体をつくり変えるかもしれない
人間と人間じゃないものの
間の存在になるかもしれない
あるいは 地球を出ていくような人たちは
そもそも地球的なものが嫌で
出ていくのかもしれない
反地球的な考え方を持った集団として
行くのかもしれない
倫理の前提が変わると言いましたが
倫理の前提が変わるということは
その人たちは違う倫理を
持つかもしれないんです
違う倫理を持った人というのは
我々にとって良いと思うことを
良いと思わず
悪いと思うことを
良いと思うのかもしれない
そういう集団ができることは
我々にとって幸せなのかというと
それは 微妙だなと思います
もう今から何十年も前に
生物学者のホールデンさんが
こんな言葉を残しています
「宇宙というのは
我々が想像する以上に奇妙などころか
想像できる以上に奇妙なところなんだ」と
つまり 宇宙で花開く
人類の多様性というのはですね
なんかこう「みんな違ってみんな良いな」
バラ色な世界ではなくて
恐らく今の我々にとって
気持ち悪い 恐ろしい グロテスクな
そういう新たな存在が
宇宙にできることだと思います
さあ皆さん
そんな未来を欲しいですか？
まぁなんとも言えないですよね
なんとも言えないです
そのアンビバレンスこそが
僕は宇宙の魅力だと思っています
別の人の言葉を最後に紹介します
京大の人類学者 生態学者で有名な
今西 錦司先生のお言葉
今西先生が 宇宙を語った
こんな言葉を残しています
「私なんかは 自分の一生については
自然が破壊されていくのを悲しんだりしている
けれども人間の一生を考えたら
サイボーグでもなんでもいいから
もっともっと発展して欲しい
という気持ちになるね」と
分かりますか？
自分ひとりの一生
自分の身の回り 自分の子供たち
自分の友人たち
そういうことを考えたらですね
やっぱり今の自然が良い
今の地球で持っている倫理が良い
あまり変なことをしたくない
だけども 自分ひとりの一生ではなくて
この宇宙に生まれた人類として
あるいは生命として
この先 どこまで人類が
続くのか分かりませんが
その人類がどこまで
発展というかですね
何かを生み出し得るだろうか
ということを考えた時は
今の我々の感覚からすれば
怖くて恐ろしくて気持ち悪いものだとしても
やっぱり遺伝子工学だろうが
サイボーグだろうが
何でもいいから どんどん どんどん
行け行けどんどんで
発展していって欲しいと
この２つの矛盾する考え方を
同時に持つということを
今井先生は言っています
僕自身も同じことを感じます
この地球上でですね
画一化された文化で
ずっとこの地球上で
持続可能な社会をつくるためにですね
大きな発展もないまま
ずっと続いていく
それよりは やっぱり新しいものを何か
この宇宙に生まれてきたからには
生み出したい
でもそれが —
その生み出すものが 今の我々を
幸せにしてくれるものかといったら
多分それは微妙 というか
違うんじゃないかって思う
このある種の宇宙と人間の関係の
アンビバレンス
これ自身が
宇宙と人文社会科学という学問の
魅力だと思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）